christmas some know it as the most
wonderful time of the year a time for
snow hot chocolate family and a sense of
magic in the air others know it as a
time of stress last minute shopping
canceled flights and relatives you'd
rather not be stuck in a room with no
matter how you feel about christmas
there's one thing we can all agree on it
only comes once a year right well that
might be true in most of the world but
the scp foundation came across one
particular little town where the
christmas party never stops for better
or for much much worse scp-784
is a neighborhood in a small texas town
made up of 24 houses and two apartment
buildings every last one of them is
decorated top to bottom in bright
twinkling christmas lights no matter how
hot it is outside and texas summers can
be brutal the ground is always blanketed
with at least 12 centimeters of snow
curiously there is never any visible
snowfall happening in the neighborhood
that would explain this the snow is just
always there it might look inviting from
the outside a quaint little neighborhood
where the snow never melts and the
christmas lights never go out but the
folks at the scp foundation know by now
that things are rarely ever what they
seem all the houses in
scp-784 are occupied by beings referred
to as
scp-784-1 they appear to be completely
ordinary mostly adult humans dressed in
traditional christmas sweaters there are
approximately 300 people living in
scp-784
and they appear to age like normal
people though no deaths of scp-784-1
have ever been observed the citizens of
scp-784 spend their time doing
activities exclusively associated with
christmas and the holiday season they
sing christmas carols perform christmas
pageants throw eggnog festivals give
gifts and decorate their homes when the
sun goes down the activities turn to
acts of christmas-themed vandalism
decorating any object or living thing
deemed not cheerful enough by any means
necessary when a foundation supply
convoy stopped near scp-784 for the
night in order to refuel they got to
experience this maniacal dedication to
the christmas spirit first hand first
the foundation vehicles were egged
drawing the attention of the personnel
on board as the foundation operatives
chased off the egg-based assailants they
left several vehicles unattended when
they returned they found their vehicles
and equipment changed into something a
bit more festive first they noticed that
a humvee had been converted into a
sleigh then upon checking the inventory
of a weapon shipment on board they
realized the fragmentation grenades had
been replaced with glass christmas
ornaments and antlers had been welded
onto the 156 safety helmets in their
possession unsettled by these changes
and the speed at which the seemingly
human instances of
scp-784-1 had been able to make them the
personnel attempted to drive away when
they started their engines they were
shocked at a loud sputtering sound and
bursts of nutmeg-scented smoke while
they were gone their fuel tanks had been
filled with eggnog if this encounter
wasn't enough to demonstrate that
scp-784 was not to be trifled with there
were several incidents of scp foundation
agents entering the bounds of the
neighborhood and failing to adequately
perform the required christmas
celebrations when someone's christmas
cheer is not up to par instances of
scp-784-1 in the vicinity respond
immediately and aggressively
incapacitating the offending person and
forcing them into the nearest house five
different foundation agents have been
abducted in this way so far the first
foundation agent to be abducted was
agent paulson while patrolling through
scp-784 dressed in a rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer sweater and a santa
hat agent paulson made the grave mistake
of wishing a passing person happy
holidays in the blink of an eye the mood
around her darkened eight stone-faced
people with their holly jolly attire
surrounded agent paulson she attempted
to draw her weapon to defend herself but
simply was not fast enough thrashing and
screaming for help agent paulson was
dragged into a nearby home kicking over
an inflatable snowman on the way in next
agent matthews was on night patrol when
a bout of spontaneous caroling broke out
he joined in singing silent night in an
attempt to blend in with the instances
of
scp-784-1 unfortunately he misremembered
the lyrics to the song and began singing
the third verse while everyone else was
on the second while still singing the
citizens overwhelmed agent matthews and
tied him up with a string of decorative
red and green lights agent sanderson who
was supervising the patrol attempted to
intervene and free matthews which
attracted the attention of more
instances of scp-784-1
both agents were overwhelmed by the
crowd restrained and pulled into a home
for what can only be described as
christmas carol reprogramming observers
heard the sound of christmas carols
being sung inside for several days after
while on his patrol agent anderson
tripped and stubbed his toe hard against
a santa claus themed lawn gnome
overwhelmed by pain and irritation
anderson swore loudly and violently for
a duration of 14 seconds at the sound of
his salty language three instances of
scp-784-1
sprang into action and grabbed anderson
before he could react two held his body
in place restraining his arms and
forcing him to his knees the third held
his head still tilting it back and
forcing his mouth open a fourth instance
emerged from a house carrying a cord of
eggnog as anderson struggled to no avail
the eggnog was poured into his mouth
until the court was empty and he
collapsed limply on the ground once he
was rendered unconscious the instances
of
scp-784-1 dragged him inside finally
agent davids was observing the
neighborhood when he was offered a
present by one of the few children in
the town a young girl wearing a sparkly
green and red sweater and a headband
decorated with reindeer antlers davids
accepted the gif with a forced smile and
thanked the little girl but apparently
did not respond with enough enthusiasm
when he failed to give the reaction she
was looking for the little girl tackled
him with a surprising amount of force
grabbing him around his legs and
knocking him to the ground before he
could regain his balance and climb to
his feet several more children emerged
from a nearby house and dragged david's
inside pulling him by his arms and legs
between one and three days after they
were taken the abducted personnel
emerged from the house they were pulled
into they were all dressed in new more
elaborate christmas wear from light up
sweaters to headbands covered in tiny
presents when a supervisor attempted to
extract the foundation personnel the
personnel refused to leave when the
issue was pressed further the instances
of
scp-784-1 around them became
increasingly aggressive and even violent
in their attempt to protect the abducted
agent paulson matthews anderson
sanderson and david's are still within
the boundaries of scp-784
and are all considered lost the official
story is that they died in the line of
duty in order to protect their families
from the truth
scp-784-1's fixation on christmas spirit
doesn't only extend to humans and
inanimate objects any living being
within the walls of scp-784 that doesn't
look festive enough is subject to a
swarm of citizens decorating it and that
includes animals during several patrols
foundation personnel have observed 15
stray cats given red collars with a
small bell seven stray dogs adorned with
reindeer antlers rabbits and raccoons
with santa hats forced onto their heads
and even deer dressed up to resemble the
iconic rudolph out of an abundance of
caution and in an attempt to prevent any
future abductions there have been
extreme limits placed on the number of
staff allowed to patrol inside of
scp-784 the foundation currently only
sends in agents under special
circumstances most notably for a regular
occurrence known as a noel event about
once a month instances of
scp-784-1 will attempt to exit the
boundaries of scp-784
and enter a nearby neighborhood in the
suburban community that's around 784.
each member of the community carries a
15-meter long string of christmas lights
and they wander in a group until they
have found an undecorated house they
will begin to promptly decorate this
house winding the christmas lights
around it until it looks identical to
the rest of the houses in scp-784
it is unclear what happens to the
residents of the chosen house but it is
likely that they are converted into
scp-784-1
much like the abducted foundation agents
naturally the foundation has a vested
interest in preventing scp-784 from
expanding and is dedicated to tracking
and preventing these noel events noel
events do not happen on an exact
schedule but the foundation has become
aware of certain warning signs that one
may be coming prior to a noel event
scp-784-1 becomes more actively festive
during the day notably increasing their
singing decorating and eggnog
consumption when these signs have been
noted a select team of personnel is
ordered to execute procedure 784-c
a preventative measure employed to stop
the noel event from occurring when
procedure 784-c has been ordered to
commence foundation personnel dress up
in santa outfits and position themselves
by the exit points of
scp-784 they sing the classic carol good
king wenslas and pass out non-alcoholic
eggnog to the other personnel stationed
with them naturally this draws the
attention of scp-784-1
unable to resist the allure of holiday
cheer and goodwill towards men once they
have arrived the personnel distribute a
secondary batch of eggnog to scp-784-1
this one mixed with a mild sedative
after the eggnog has been passed out the
foundation personnel are to sing carols
with the citizens of scp-784 as the
sedative takes effect as instances of
scp-784-1 begin to pass out their
neighbors will silently carry them into
their designated homes on their own
until all of them have fallen asleep if
procedure 784-c happens to fail for any
reason the foundation personnel are
instructed to release a sleeping gas
into the town and restrain the citizens
until they have been rendered
unconscious then they are all to be
placed in their homes by personnel if
the members of any nearby communities
express concern a standard cover story
of a neighborhood football watch party
gone a little too far
is released to the public in order to
prevent civilians from accidentally
happening upon
scp-784 the neighborhood has been
disguised as an ordinary gated community
it is surrounded by a 3.5 meter high 0.8
meter thick concrete wall topped with an
electrified steel cable the foundation
is not allowed to prevent non-foundation
personnel from entering in order to
mitigate the risk of a violent reaction
from scp-784-1
however when an individual not related
to the foundation is spotted leaving the
neighborhood they are to be swiftly
detained interrogated and given an
amnesic no foundation personnel are
permitted to enter the neighborhood
unless they are dressed in christmas
attire these personnel must also be
armed with a knowledge of all basic
christmas carols the area is to be
monitored at all times via
foundation-owned weather balloon and the
citizens of scp-784 are to be watched
for unusual behavior and the signs of an
impending noel event scp-784
is currently classified as euclid and is
considered to be largely non-threatening
as long as it continues to be contained
the citizens of scp-784 are not overtly
harming anyone and they don't seem to
want anything more than to celebrate
christmas forever however it's uncertain
how far they would attempt to expand if
noel events were allowed to occur with
no intervention perhaps they would
expand forever forcing eggnog down
throats and strangling houses with
twinkling lights turning the world as we
know it into a twisted snow globe
hopefully we'll never have to find out
just be careful if you're wandering
through the suburbs of texas and hear
the jingling of sleigh bells in july or
you might find yourself on
scp-784's naughty list now go check out
trapped in a game scp-1733
season opener and the skin stealers
scp-3333
tower for more places you hope to never
find yourself